рік тому стало так само
підтвердження перемир'я
вигукнув там ми теж
спочатку видно незначні тілесні ушкодження
а перемир'я то більше має
утримується протягом двох місяців або менше
а оскільки тільки в листопаді були бої
знову збільшився з усієї сили і
відтоді безперервно до
різні фокусні точки
палили далі і пасха спец
Місія спостерігачів також має це
спостерігати та повідомляти про ситуацію
непередбачуваний, всі ознаки є
для боротьби в будь-який час
зброя не може їх формувати
повністю відклеєні і боки
стояти занадто близько один до одного
зараз потрібні дії по контактній лінії
включно з розплутуванням сторін
інші координаційні точки навколо
стабілізувати перемир'я і в
розширюватися в довгостроковій перспективі